foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that means that we
royalty
[Music]
you don't love me
afternoon
that needs me a wife
even if we have to part you and me us
have one heart
[Music]
don't get off my lap you I'll write you
every day
nothing but that can keep me from it
you must ain't got no Kinfolk around
these parts all I had was my sister
she was the only one ever loved me
it's time for you to see the world
there's gonna be some changes made put
it on this ain't me hush we need to look
like we belong let's see the smile and
come
oh sweet and loving God
now it's okay
huh
[Music]
dear Celie we have more than just kings
and queens
we are at the center of the universe
foreign
[Music]